now rather than offering their own
positive pro-growth agenda for America
the Democrats have gone really negative
and really nasty they casually hurled
charges of racism at conservative
targets of course including at the
President himself well I think this
country hasn't dealt well with the
issues of race I mean we have a
president who's a racist who we have you
believe in his heart he's a racist well
I don't know what in his heart means
Ohio must be really proud well Trump is
the first president to try to reverse
the bleed of manufacturing jobs from
Ohio the old Rust Belt and being called
a racist is how he's repaid by sherrod
Brown well of course he's probably going
to be joining the 2020 race and so he
has to join in with the rest of the race
hucksters who are dividing America under
the guise of tolerance in their America
the wall is racist deporting illegals is
racist ice is racist century-old
monuments their racist assimilation
definitely racist requiring English be
spoken
absolutely racist college Indian mascot
so they were way racist way beyond
blackface many costumes are now racist
but now liberals are in a huge pickle
how do they maintain the racial bona
fide ease when one of their own
governors cut loose during a med school
Halloween party dressed like this well
of course with the release of this image
on Friday the career of Virginia
Governor Ralph Northam hangs in the
balance now well what initially the Gov
apologized I'm deeply sorry I cannot
change the decisions I made but I accept
responsibility for my past actions and I
am ready to do the hard work of
regaining your trust but then at a press
conference the next day North Rim was
like picture what picture I am NOT the
person in that photo that same year I
did participate in a dance contest in
San Antonio in which I darken my face is
part of a Michael Jackson costume I used
us a little bit of shoe polish to put
under my or on my cheeks and the reason
I used a very little bit is because I
don't know if anybody's ever tried that
but you cannot get shoe polish off oh my
god ed gillespie lost to him that's what
I keep thinking watching he's gotta be
kidding me
well Democrats of course moved too
quickly jettison him knowing he can
become the Todd Aiken of the 2020 race
first of all I think that the governor
should resign he should resign I mean
there's just no question that he should
resign so it's more Pat long past time
for him to just step down he should step
down and start his road to redemption or
at least becoming a vegan now Nancy
Pelosi the Democratic National Committee
Kamala Harris Kirsten Gillibrand and Joe
Biden all rushed out with statements
demanding that Northam resign as well
the left now finds itself hoisted on its
own petard to satisfy their nutbag base
Democrats have set themselves up as
these PC Puritans a band of politically
correct enforcers who traverse the
culture stamping out any and all who
violate their ever-shifting ethical
codes so now everybody is walking on
eggshells everywhere to avoid being
called out for white privilege or gender
privilege without the privilege of
knowing what this new orthodoxy even
requires Ralph Northam fate will
ultimately be decided by Democrats in
the Commonwealth and and Republicans
would do well to avoid joining the PC
Puritans of the left because the
Democrats they're tripping all over
themselves to prove how enlightened they
are by throwing even their own under the
PC Express
I find it richly ironic that Joe Biden
was one of the first to tweet out
there's no place for racism in America
Governor Northam has lost all more
authority and should resign immediately
well the Democrat frontrunner and a new
Iowa poll of course Biden has a lot of
nerve after all this is a guy who said
this of his own future running mate
clean and who can forget this charming
observation from Amtrak Joe you cannot
go to a unless you have a slight Indian
accent the Washington Examiner has now
dug up an NPR transcript from 1975 where
Biden talks about his support for
segregated schools
so is this disqualifying the New
Democratic Party is Biden after all
these years been in the Senate for all
these years vice president for eight
years
is he just a deep-seated racist and
capable of running for president on the
Democratic ticket I think you all get
the point this is going in a bad
direction for the Democrats and probably
for the rest of us as well but each time
the Dems highlight the evolving purity
of their party and reach into the past
to convict someone today they end up
distancing themselves from America now
yesterday it was Magga hats that were
racist but today anyone who ever
impersonated Michael Jackson at a dance
party might as well have burned a cross
on someone's lawn former Democratic
congressman Jim Moran a Northam defender
put it this way this weekend I think it
is a rush to judgment before we know all
of the facts and before we've considered
all of the consequences even if the
worst case scenario is true George I
think there is an issue of redemption
oh no redemption forgiveness which was
once only reserved for the left is now
unavailable for them too absolutely seen
with Kevin Hart
Al Franken the PC Puritans get to decide
who is Orthodox and who is unclean and
they alone decide whom to burn at the
stake but don't be deceived this whole
effort is in fact a smokescreen my
friends it's a party wide effort to
distract from the Democrats reliability
I think they're atrocious policies and
what we should be focusing on so
everyone's locked on Northam skate cake
costume mess and it's a mess let's not
forget how he came to national
prominence last week it was his
abhorrent defense of the Democrats
abortion on demand at all stages agenda
the infant would be delivered the infant
would be kept comfortable the infant
would be resuscitated if that's what the
mother and the family desired and then a
discussion would ensue between the
physicians and the mother now he's the
one who needs to be resuscitated the
exposure of the grisly reality that the
Democrats desire abortion even after
birth has startled voters across the
political spectrum it should but
suddenly we're talking about 30 year old
pictures instead of a murderous policy
that imperils the lives of thousands of
children today Republicans should not
fall into this trap avoid the identity
politics and the PC Puritans stick to
the facts and to the issues we win on
those Democrats are vulnerable on those
most Americans are unaware for instance
that when Democratic Governor Andrew
Cuomo signed that law at the standing
ovation expanding abortion in New York
last week he simultaneously removed
abortion from the state's Criminal Code
so now New York permits the abortion of
a child beyond 24 weeks for essentially
any reason and infanticide is no longer
illegal let the Democrats continue their
witch hunts the stalks in the town
square will surely be full Republicans
should keep connecting with the rest of
America who fear that come 2020 we could
be heading off the rails of prosperity
and towards socialism and that's the
angle